this video sponsored by brilliant org
the first 200 people to click the link
in the description will get 20% off the
annual premium subscription hey
wisecrack jared here and i promise i'm
not here to beat a dead tauntaun as i'm
sure everyone knows the last Jedi pissed
off a lot of fans a wisecrack we've
surfaced the usual rant Luke Skywalker
is suddenly a green milk chugging coward
Snoke gets Darth Maul before we know
anything about him holed OHS plan
doesn't make any sense the Kanto bite
section is boring Rey's parents were a
red herring Marvel humor for days this
is Huck's
and of course Leia Poppins but we're not
gonna spend 15 minutes fanboy rages
instead we're gonna discuss how Rian
Johnson tried to revolutionize Star Wars
but didn't so what went wrong well to
answer that we'll need a little help
from a guy who in a roundabout way is
responsible for making Star Wars Star
Wars nope not that guy this guy welcome
to spice crack edition on the last Jedi
what went wrong and spoiler alert even
though I already spoiled pretty much
everything now Before we jump in if
you'll allow me to get a little meta on
you the relationship between kylo Ren
and Darth Vader can be interpreted as a
commentary on the relationship new Star
Wars has with the original Star Wars
that you will never be as strong as
Darth Vader in the force awakens kylo
Ren is burdened by the task of living up
to the legend of his grandfather just as
the new series has the seemingly
impossible pressure of living up to the
legacy of the original trilogy just as
kylo Ren mimics Darth Vader by dressing
like him and using a voice modulator
even though there's nothing wrong with
his voice so too does the force awakens
mimic a new hope as many critics have
noticed it's almost beat per beep the
same movie this may seem like a stretch
but the dynamic between Snoke and kylo
in the opening of the last Jedi furthers
this meta reading as Snoke tells kylo to
take off the stupid mask
and that he shouldn't even bother
anymore
no Veda just a child and then Ren breaks
the mask they might as well go and throw
Luke's lightsaber off a cliff oh wait
Johnson is telegraphing to his audience
that this will no longer be a rehash of
the original trilogy the film will be a
radical subversion of the Star Wars
formula for the new Star Wars to live
the old Star Wars must die but the past
time kill it if you have to with the
last Jedi Brian Johnson isn't interested
in recycling old Star Wars he's
interested in progress not only
progressing the franchise itself but the
landscape of a certain galaxy far far
away in order to progress the franchise
Johnson abrasively undermines the troops
and traditions that characterized the
previous films where as Luke Skywalker
was the son of noble blood Rey's parents
are just degenerate winos they were
nobody there are filthy junk treasures
sold you offer drinking money our heroes
are now janitors and mechanics instead
of politicians and princesses Luke is no
longer the idealistic hero he's a failed
nephew murderer / lenient philosopher
Yoda goes from symbol of Jedi piety to
would-be book burner and the Jedi Order
kind of sucks lesson two now that
they're extinct the Jedi are romanticize
deified if you strip away the myth and
look at their deeds legacy of the Jedi
is failure hypocrisy hubris that's not
true at the height of their powers they
allow Darth Sidious to Rhys create the
Empire and wipe them out it was a Jedi
Master who was responsible for the
training and creation of Darth Vader so
you might be asking why on everything
that define the previous films well cos
turns out the events of the previous
films didn't really lead to any progress
after the collapse of the Empire a
nearly identical Nazi inspired fascistic
Order has risen so clearly something is
wrong in the galaxy if this keeps
happening so what's to blame for this
re-emergence of evil
well Johnson seems to suggest it's our
inadequate conception of good and evil
but wait
start divisions between good and evil
are what the entire Star Wars mythology
has been built around it's the dark side
not the dark nuance and here's where the
movie almost gets really smart as many
of you may know George Lucas crafted the
original trilogy point four point around
a book called the hero with a thousand
faces written by Joseph Campbell the
book sets forth a kind of universal
story structure from which myths stories
and literature all borrow which is why
the structure is called the monomyth but
instead of simply recycling Campbell's
monomyth as seen in the original trilogy
Johnson uses it to complicate our
relationship with the dark side is the
Campbell's monomyth is based on the work
of psychoanalyst Carl Jung who wrote
about ideas like the collective
unconscious and archetypes universal
primordial images ingrained deep in our
psyche those archetypes for Campbell
inform the kind of characters that keep
popping up in stories across continents
and cultures so let's talk about one of
those archetypes the shadow and how the
last Jedi tries to radically redefine
our relationship to it for Jung the
shadow is the primal or animal part of
our unconscious that tends to get
repressed the dark side see what we're
going with this
in the monomyth this dark side usually
gets embodied by a character who
represents the shortcomings fears and
anxieties of our protagonist golem is
Frodo's shadow a stark reminder of what
he could become but if you really want
shadows 101 look no further than Darth
Vader and Luke Skywalker Darth Vader was
once a powerful Jedi who succumbed to
the darkside for Luke Darth Vader serves
as a constant reminder of what he could
become if he does not conquer his fear
and master his passions so confronting
Darth Vader is more than just a physical
confrontation
it's an emotional and psychological one
it's why Luke spares Darth Vader's life
if he were to strike him down in anger
then he's lost the battle with his inner
demons but whereas the old Star Wars
wants you to conquer your inner demons
the new Star Wars has other ideas in all
of the films we're meant to believe that
balance in the force is desirable for
the good of the galaxy you refer to the
prophecy of the one who will bring
balance to the force
you believe it's this boy however the
last Jedi suggests that the force is
something that inherently promotes
balance when the darkness Rises the
force amplifies the light to balance it
out darkness rises and light to meet it
I warned my young apprentice that as he
grew stronger is equal in the light
would rise if we're to believe Snoke
here wouldn't that mean that the inverse
is true that any powerful Jedi Order
would be met with an equally powerful
dark side if so we have no choice but to
read luke's criticism of the Jedi Order
as one that blames them in part for the
cyclical rise and fall of these fascist
empires while it's kind of ambiguous
this logical conclusion seems to be
hinted at by Luke with episode 8 the
dark side is no longer something to be
conquered by the valiant Jedi at the
behest of the light side because that
will make the Force over correct to
achieve balance leading to more
amplifications of evil according to
Union analyst Robert a Johnson not to be
confused with Rian Johnson we shouldn't
think of our dark sides as something to
merely conquer and expunge Johnson says
this act of repression causes us to
accumulate the darkness which creates an
ego split according to his reading of
you when you suppress the darkness
you're forced to find a scapegoat
project all your own ugliness onto them
leading to a never ending fight this is
quite literally done in the very way the
original Star Wars is written with
Luke's inner demons projected onto an
evil space wizard instead of maintaining
this classic distinction between good
and bad
both within our characters and in the
general plot Rian Johnson tries to
complicate it at every step of the way
as we see conquering evil with good
hasn't done much for the galaxy the
Empire is basically back with a sexy new
rebranding and Snoke is basically
Palpatine 2.0 in earlier Star Wars the
good bad distinction is literally black
and
white and thus the force awakens brings
us right back to where we started
so to progress the franchise Rian
Johnson tweaks the basic Yunus formula
if you've suggested that we must
reconcile our dark side with the rest of
our personality does the galaxy need to
reconcile its dark side with the larger
order of things balance consider Benicio
Del Toro's character DJ rather than
upholding the traditional distinction
between purely good rebels and purely
evil oppressors he explores how even the
good guys can get caught up in the
darker elements of the universe as the
galaxy's very own Blackwater mercenary
the cynical DJ sees through the false
divisions of good and evil
at least you're stealing from the bad
guys and helping the good good guys bad
guys made upwards let's see who formerly
owned made his bank selling weapons to
the bad guys
and the good this marks the most morally
ambiguous moments in any Star Wars film
when he not only suggests that divisions
between good and evil are insincere and
unhelpful but complicates our
understanding of the rebellion as an
infallible good Robert Johnson sees our
traditional understanding of the light
and dark sides as straight-up dangerous
he says that our inability to reconcile
with our shadow and therefore our
eventual scapegoating onto others will
inevitably end in violence war and
racism for the last Jedi rather than the
good guys and bad guys there's a system
at play his little machine partner live
free don't join it becomes the first
Star Wars film to explicitly critique
the galaxy's military economy and the
exploitation and animal rights
violations inherent in it which even
heroes like Princess Leia are party to
then shelled us to test their weapons so
you might be asking at this point aside
from being too ballsy what went wrong
well the movie goes out of its way to in
both form and content tell us that we
must kill the past whether it be the
past structure of Star Wars films or the
moral lens we understood the previous
films through then this happens it's
time to little things die
smoke Skywalker
as if
the Jedi the rebels let it all die ray
I want you to join me ray is given a
chance to end all the dogmatism of the
previous films and yet she says no and
from this point on its all backpedal
central no no you're still holding on
that drop all the things that we were
convinced need to be killed are
reaffirmed tearing down the heroic
archetypes inherent in the monomyth
Jemma was burning he'd vanished with a
handful of my students and slaughtered
the rest Leia blend smoke but it was me
I failed because I was Luke Skywalker
Jedi Master
a legend nope The Legend of Luke
Skywalker lives on inspiring the galaxy
once again and this time as an added
bonus it's a lie gay necessity to tear
down established orders that delineate
the division between good and evil
time for the Jedi to end nope I will not
be the last Jedi desire to distance
itself from the established narrative
structure of the original trilogy nope
strike me down and anger and I'll always
be with you
powerful magicks forget the Jedi Pass
nope
save the books it's not that movies
can't insert ideas and then ultimately
reject them but usually the ideological
shift happens as the plot pushes our
heroes to reconsider their ideas in
interesting and thought-provoking ways
instead Luke decides to reaffirm all the
antiquated ideas because he loves his
sister I guess other reversals are
equally perplexing don't be a hero until
it's okay to be a hero and by this point
the film has made a psychologically
sophisticated case for why ray should
team up with Ren the old way doesn't
work
Jedi's are repressed as hell and were
stuck playing a galactic game of Nazi
whack-a-mole fine we need a radical
change which is literally what Ren seems
to be offering despite her faith in
Ren's essential goodness and despite
Luke's lesson that the forces beyond
good and evil Rey hesitates here's where
ray and Ren become opposing stand-ins
for the film's to potential moral codes
Ren is the realist who knows that the
rebels will try to impose the same moral
expectations onto ray as they did to
Luke having become well acquainted with
his bad side and his good and wisely
calling out the folly of the false
division Ren is arguably closer to
finding that Union balance than most he
seems to be offering to Rey exactly what
robert johnson and young say a person
should strive for recognition that the
ego and shadow are both part of a person
and what's more that one literally can
not exist without the other meanwhile
Rey represents the old moral code of
Star Wars the temptation to run away
with her swoll new crush is ultimately
overcome by her desire to be the good
Jedi a morally pure infallible hero who
definitely isn't suppressing a lifetime
supply of Darkness no siree
so if you're gonna revolutionize Star
Wars great want to reframe how we think
about the central conflict cool but
spending all this time abrasively
subverting everything we love and know
about Star Wars just do shrug and revert
back to where we started less cool but
what do you think wisecrack is this
latest iteration of Star Wars
sacrilegious or a much-needed fresh take
on the series let us know what you think
in the comments and as always thanks for
watching peace now while the last Jedi
had its problems so too does my life
recently my social media account was
hacked by a troll an actual living under
a bridge troll he held my Twitter
captive unless I could answer this brain
teaser from brilliant org suppose two
people standing in place are holding a
rope firmly so it doesn't slip through
their hands which of the two people can
apply a greater force on the rope the
person with stronger muscles the person
with greater mass or will they both
apply equal force I was clueless until I
checked out brilliant org website that
makes learning math science and logic
feel like an arcade game personally I
love their physics of every day module
which helped me get the riddle right and
now I have my Twitter back to find more
awesome puzzles in the solution head to
brilliant org slash wisecrack or click
the link in the description not only
will they email you the solution for
free if you're one of the first 200
people to click on the link you'll get
20% off an annual subscription that's it
for today gonna go update my passwords
peace y'all